there's so many comedians where they
feel like
um i don't
i don't want to say it's like oh so many
but like this is the thing we're like if
you're not spitting truth to power if
you're not tearing down the walls of the
democracy what are you even doing on
stage and it's like
the thing that i really
helped me during a pandemic especially
when i couldn't get on stage especially
when i was doing zoom shows and i didn't
want to do zoom shows and i remember
showing up and seeing dave caldwell
the denver superfan who goes to every
freaking show that i've ever done at
comedy works i've seen him there's so
many times he has a shotgun laughs that
people either love or hate and just
seeing him in that zoom and how him
talking afterwards and being like he's
like i used to go to shows every week
and now i can't and i need something to
fill that void and it's like
oh yeah i forgot my fucking job
my job is to make this shitty place we
live in better and if i can do that
either small little bit for a half an
hour an hour 90 minutes then i'm doing
something positive in this world i'm
doing something that is worthwhile and
so you might get up there and be like
well ron just does jokes about rugrats
or his family or butts or whatever but
i'm like
for if you coming to my shows my whole
premise my whole thing from beginning to
end from my openers to the music
playlist that i pick out before shows
every bit of it is designed for you to
leave going oh i feel refreshed i feel
better joyful i don't leave feeling bad
about myself feeling like i did
something wrong feeling like i vote i
hate the person next to me i mean it
really is
it just it kind of breaks my heart and
pisses me off to hear you say that
because it's like it's never been our
job yes a lot of comedians that we
respect have talked about politics and
social issues but like you know as
someone that is a white woman
even me just being successful without
making statements constantly is a
triumph just a black comedian being rich
and successful
you're already breaking down walls thank
you so much for knowing that i'm rich in
success okay
like you're like i've done my part it's
all you people that got stuff that you
didn't deserve why don't you work on the
walls that need to be broken
the ones that you fucking parkoured off
of to benefit yourself like why don't
you do that work and allow us just just
to stay focused it's what drives me nuts
when
i always get these fucking texts and
calls from people who are like hey i
hear louis ck's performing in louisville
what do you think i'm like what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do about it
i don't work for the louisville improv i
don't i already have to work twice as
hard to get half as far it's not my job
to deal with the behavior of other
people in my field it's not yours either
and us just doing what we're doing in an
honest fearless unique original way
that's already breaking down walls
so how about you motherfuckers that
built the walls how about you tear them
down so we can just stay funny
i'm saying the same shit that oppressed
uh it's not you know our job to take him
down with comedy and i guess it's just
it's already so revolutionary for people
to actually pay money to see a woman and
think she's funny that let me just try
to stay funny also it's just a thing of
like
there's only i got only so many things
to think about and focus on at the given
time um you can assume that if you have
a cause that is worthwhile and positive
that i am for you but just because you
don't see me speak about something
within that given week or that hour
doesn't mean
that i'm your enemy it doesn't mean that
i'm like
not for but to
uh
have that louis ck grammy thing because
i got a bunch of dms about that would be
like why aren't you speaking out about
louis ck winning a grammy it's a it
affects your whole thing i'm like
you're not gonna get me to care about
the grammys
no matter who wins a fucking
[Music]
four four grammy five
[Music]
[Applause]